par contre ça vous a montré ce que les
américains pensent au fond de nous on a
été leur porte parole
nous on leur a donné la vérité oui je
voulais dans vos chansons vous rendez
glamour le style de vie des gangs les
armes et la drogue
notre art est le reflet de notre réalité
vous voyez quoi vous quand vous surfez
kivu moi je sais ce que je vois et c'est
loin d'être glamour décalage qui
viennent de russie et de la cocaïne qui
vient de colombie et aucun nom d'un
passeport donc de riez vérifiez vos
sources
vous allez être plus attentifs à ce que
vous dites et comment lorsqu'on a un nom
la liberté d'expression concerne aussi
le rap non alors nous on fait rien
d'autre qu' appliquer premier amendement
et c'est le gouvernement qui l'a écrit